This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedyapur. In June 2011, the Stanley Cup finals were underway in Vancouver. The city's beloved home hockey team, the Kanaaks, were playing against the Boston Bruins. It was game 7. The team that won would take home the cup. Return the cup to Canada or add to a legacy build decades ago. In the last seconds of the game, Tim Thomas of the Bruins defended the goal and secured the championship for Boston. For the first time in 39 years, the Boston Bruins have won the Stanley Cup. Meanwhile, crowds began forming outside of the stadium in downtown Vancouver. They were upset. Just a few blocks from the stadium, fans decked out in Kenaxe
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔。2011年6月，斯坦利杯总决赛正在温哥华如火如荼地进行。这座城市挚爱的主场冰球队——加人队，正在对阵波士顿棕熊队。那是第七场比赛。获胜的球队将捧走奖杯，将奖杯带回加拿大，或是延续数十年前建立的辉煌传奇。在比赛的最后几秒钟，棕熊队的蒂姆·托马斯成功守住球门，为波士顿锁定胜局。这是39年来波士顿棕熊队首次赢得斯坦利杯。与此同时，温哥华市中心体育馆外开始聚集人群。他们感到非常沮丧。就在距离体育馆仅几个街区的地方，身穿加人队
jerseys began destroying the city. They smashed windows and looted local businesses. Cars were overturned and set on fire. Jim Chu was police chief at the time. He was working crowd control, just blocks away from the center of the chaos that day. 10 years later, he reflected on what happened that evening. It's hard to explain what happens when people get into a crowd mentality. And some of these riders told us, I got caught up in the moment.
球衣的球迷开始破坏这座城市。他们砸碎窗户，洗劫当地商铺。汽车被掀翻并纵火焚烧。吉姆·楚当时是警察局长。那天，他就在距离混乱中心仅几个街区的敌方负责维持人群秩序。10年后，他回想起当晚发生的事情。很难解释当人们陷入群体心态时会发生什么。其中一些暴徒告诉我们，我当时是一时冲动被卷进去的。
One of the reasons I want to talk about it. What could lead people to wreak havoc on their own city? How could ordinary fans so easily turn into violent rioters? This week on Hidden Brain, the psychological transformation that overcomes people when they become part of a group. You have certainly had moments in your life when you were swept up by the fervor of the people around you. Maybe you broke into dance for the first time at a boy's dress party and forgot your
这也是我想谈论的原因之一。究竟是什么导致人们对自己的城市大肆破坏？普通球迷怎么会如此轻易地变成暴力暴徒？本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨当人们成为群体的一部分时，内心发生的心理转变。在你的生活中，肯定也曾有过被周围人的狂热情绪席卷的时刻。也许你在某个单身派对上生平第一次跳起舞来，抛开了所有的
inhibitions. Perhaps you felt moved during an emotional wedding to make a revealing personal speech. Or maybe you felt your blood pressure rising at a political rally and found yourself sucked in by the mood of the crowd around you. Mina Chikara is a psychologist at Harvard University. She studies what happens to us in these moments. She explores how being part of a group can be powerfully transformative and how we can learn to keep our heads when everyone around us is losing theirs. Mina Chikara, welcome to Hidden Brain heads when everyone around us is losing theirs. Mina Chikara, welcome to Hidden Brain.
拘束。也许在情绪激动的婚礼上，你深受触动，发表了一番袒露心迹的个人演讲。或者，你可能在一次政治集会上感到血压飙升，发现自己被周围人群的氛围深深裹挟。米娜·奇卡拉是哈佛大学的心理学家。她专门研究我们在这些时刻会发生什么。她探讨了成为群体的一部分如何能带来强大的改变，以及当周围所有人都在失去理智时，我们如何才能学会保持冷静。米娜·奇卡拉，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。
Thank you so much for having me. It's a pleasure to be here. Mina, I understand that you are not a sports fan, but some years ago you attended a baseball game at Yankee Stadium with a date, who was a baseball fan. Can you paint a picture for me of what it felt like on that day walking into the stadium? Sure. So I, as you say, I'm not a baseball fan. I'm not a sports fan more generally, but I really, really liked this guy, this guy who ended up being my husband eventually. And so he's a big Red Sox fan. And he was doing his post-doc at Princeton where I was a graduate student and he said, hey, the Red Sox are coming to Yankee Stadium.
非常感谢邀请我来。很高兴能来到这里。米娜，据我了解你并不是一个体育迷，但几年前你和一位身为棒球迷的约会对象一起去扬基体育场看了一场棒球比赛。你能给我描绘一下那天走进体育场时的感受吗？当然。所以正如你所说，我不是棒球迷，平时更不是体育迷，但我真的很喜欢这个最终成为我丈夫的男生。他是红袜队的超级大球迷。当时他在普林斯顿大学做博士后，而我是那里的研究生，他说，嘿，红袜队要来扬基体育场了。
Would you like to go to the game with me in New York City? So, you know, I kind of jumped at any chance to ride the train with him for an hour and a half, get up to the city, hang out at the game. And so we went up and he was kidded out and all of his Red Sox gear, his hat. And, you know, again, not really being a fan of any team. I had my regular outfit on. And it was really exciting. I mean, it was, you know, it's a fun environment going to a sporting event, right?
你想不想跟我一起去纽约市看这场比赛？所以，你知道的，只要有机会能跟他一起坐一个半小时的火车去城里，在比赛现场闲逛，我都求之于。于是我们就去了，他穿着一身红袜队的装备，戴着帽子。而且，再次声明，由于我真的不是任何球队的球迷，我穿的是自己平常的衣服。这真的让人很兴奋。我的意思是，去看体育赛事是一种很有趣的体验，对吧？
People are really boisterous. They're really excited. There's, you know, the sort of frisson of competition in the air. And, you know, I was really charmed by all of that. And I was also very charmed by spending time with him. Now the Yankees and Red Sox, of course, are storied, storied rivals, and their rivalry goes back many, many decades.
人们非常喧闹，非常兴奋。空气中弥漫着一种竞争的刺激感。你知道的，这一切真的让我深深着迷，而且花时间跟他在一起也让我感到十分陶迷。当然，扬基队和红袜队是一对有着悠久历史的死敌，两队之间的宿怨可以追溯到几十年前。
And I understand that as the game began, there was sort of light-hearted banter between your date and the Yankees fan seated around you. That's exactly right. So I'm wildly ignorant of this history as I'm coming into this game, but it becomes pretty quickly evident to me that there's a history there. And the way that this becomes evident is that, you know, as the ending is kind of go on for second inning, the game is tight, you know, everyone's playing well, we're sitting in Yankee Stadium
据我所知，比赛刚开始时，你的约会对象和坐在你周围的扬基队球迷之间，还有一些轻松的玩笑。完全正确。所以我在去看这场比赛时对这段历史完全一无所知，但很快我就明显感觉到这里面有历史渊源。这种历史感是如何显现出来的呢？随着比赛进行到第二局，比分咬得很紧，大家都发挥得很好，我们坐在扬基体育场里，
surrounded by Yankees fans and, you know, my date is wearing his red socks here. And there's some good-natured heckling going on in the early parts of the game. People poking fun at the hat or saying that the team is going to lose, but it's again good-natured. And the game eventually gets a little tense. Walk me through what happens at that point. Well, we get further and further into the game and that this the game is the tight and i'm not really paying too much attention to the game
周围全是扬基队的球迷，而我的约会对象戴着他的红袜队帽子。比赛早期大家还开着善意的玩笑，互相调侃一下帽子，或者说对方球队要输了，但这些依然是善意的。后来比赛渐渐变得有些紧张。请跟我讲讲当时发生了什么。好吧，随着比赛越来越深入，比赛比分非常紧咬，我其实并没有太关注比赛本身，
but i am starting to get an acute sense of is a bit of threat in the air and the way that this is manifesting is the folks who are sitting around as who are yinke's fans that good-natured ribbing that was going on early starts to get a little bit more aggressive here and i find that my date is also starting to get a little bit more aggressive in his responses. People are sort of chin-judding and puffing their chests. And I'm a little surprised because I'm thinking this is just a supporting event.
但我开始敏锐地感觉到空气中弥漫着一丝威胁的气息。这种威胁的表现是，周围那些扬基队球迷原本友善的打趣开始变得有些具有攻击性了，我发现我的约会对象在回应时也开始变得有些好斗。人们开始互相扬起下巴、挺起胸膛。我感到有点惊讶，因为我想这只是一场体育赛事而已。
But there's real sort of group power, it seems, to be going on here. And because the game is tight, and because the scores are very close, there's a lot of tension. And this is where I start to get worried. I worry that my date is going to get into a fight with the Yankees fan. Now, was your date the kind of person
但这里似乎正在发生一股真正的群体力量。由于比赛胶着，比分咬得很紧，现场充满了紧张气氛。正是在这个时候，我开始担心起来。我担心我的约会对象会跟扬基队的球迷打起来。那么，你的约会对象是那种
who would get into fights with people? Not to my knowledge, but what I was seeing in this moment suggested otherwise. And so I'm thinking I know how to deal with this situation. I'm going to diffuse it. I will take his red socks hat from him. And I didn't bring a bag with me or anything, so I didn't really have anywhere to put it. And I thought I was very clever by putting it on my own head thinking, well, I'm not really a fan of either team,, it doesn't matter to me if anybody says anything to me
会跟别人打架的人吗？据我所知不是，但我当时看到的景象却表明事实并非如此。所以我想我知道该怎么处理这种情况。我要化解它。我决定摘下他的红袜队帽子。我当时没带包什么的，所以也没地方放它。我觉得自己可聪明了，直接把它戴在了自己头上，心想，反正我两支球队都不是粉丝，如果有人对我说什么，我也无所谓，
I'm not going to take it personally. I just want to get this. I want to get the two of us out of Yankee Stadium in one piece Uh-huh. So you were trying to transform the hat in some ways back into just a hat So sitting on your head it wasn't as simple of anything. It would just be a hat That's right, but of course nobody around me actually knows that and so now I start to draw the eye of all the Yankees fans who are sitting around us and they start saying things to me about my mother and making comments about what my SAT scores must have been, you know, really nasty and rude language.
我不会把这放在心上。我只想带着他，把我们俩完好无损地带出扬基体育场。嗯哼。所以你某种程度上是想把这顶帽子还原成一顶普通的帽子？只要戴在你头上，它就不再代表什么特殊含义，而只是一顶普通的帽子。没错，但周围的人当然不知道这一点，于是我开始吸引周围所有扬基队球迷的目光，他们开始对我说一些关于我母亲的脏话，评论我的SAT成绩肯定很低，全都是些非常恶毒和粗鲁的言语。
And I withstood it, I think I made me took it for 10 minutes. I can't claim any longer than that. But then I started getting aggressive back. I started yelling at people's faces and telling them to, you know, mind their own business or whatever. And that really surprised me. And did you have the sense at this point that now they were two of you against the rest of them? I mean, so you and your date now were on the same side being attacked by all these people and fighting back.
我忍受了这一切，我想我大概忍了10分钟。我不敢说坚持了更长时间。但后来我也开始反击了。我开始冲着别人的脸大喊大叫，叫他们管好自己的闲事之类的。这真的让我很惊讶。你当时有没有一种感觉，觉得现在是你们两个人对抗剩下所有人？我是说，你和你的约会对象现在站在同一阵线，遭到所有人攻击并奋起反击。
Yes, there's definitely a closeness there, and there's also weirdly a growing allegiance to the Red Sox out of nowhere by virtue of being victimized for being an ostensible Red Sox. This is why it's the fact that, you know, I'm not actually a Red Sox fan. So it's sort of creating the sense of loyalty to the team in me by being treated by Yankee's fans this way. Yeah. Now, I thought to believe, but at a certain point, it almost got to the point where you felt like you would get into a physical altercation with some of the people around you.
是的，那种亲密感是显而易见的，而且莫名其妙地，由于被当作假想的红袜队球迷而遭到迫害，我对红袜队产生了一种不知从何而来的日益增长的效忠感。这就是为什么——事实上我根本不是红袜队球迷。所以，通过受到扬基队球迷这样的对待，我在不知不觉中对这支球队产生了忠诚感。是的。现在，这听起来有点难以置信，但在某个时刻，情况几乎发展到让你觉得你会和周围的人发生肢体冲突的地步。
I mean, you know, at some point, this guy started getting up into my face and, you know, you can only withstand so much talk about your mother, you know, people just saying disparaging things about you and your kin. And so I, it came out of nowhere. I found myself sort of leaning into him and he leaned back into me. It didn't much matter that, you know, he was a man and I was a woman. And I felt like I wanted to shove him and my date saw this sort of stood up between us and kind of caught me down and said, I think it may be time for us to go. How soon was it after you left Yankee Stadium, Meena? Did you start to ponder on your own behavior and the astonishing nature of the change that had come over you?
我的意思是，你知道，在某个时刻，这家伙开始凑到我脸跟前，你知道的，你对那些关于你母亲的言论、那些对你和你的亲人进行贬低的言论只能忍耐到一定程度。所以我——这完全是突如其来的。我发现自己忍不住往前倾去贴近他，他也向我倾身压过来。他是个男人而我是个女人，这一点已经不重要了。我觉得我想推他一把，而我的约会对象看到这一幕，就站到我们中间，把我拉开并对我说，我想我们可能是时候离开了。米娜，你离开扬基体育场后多久，开始反思自己的行为以及发生在你身上的那种惊人转变？
It was pretty soon thereafter that I thought, wait a second, that was really weird. I don't normally act like that in the course of my day to day life. I don't know that I've ever acted like that. I mean, maybe when I've played, you know, tennis in high school or something, I get competitive, but never to the point of sort of wanting to fight somebody over something. I don't even care about, that was very bizarre. Yeah, I mean, you were not just not a Red Sox fan, you were not even a baseball fan or a sports fan.
离开后没多久我就想，等一下，这太奇怪了。我在日常生活中通常不会那样行事。我都不知道自己有没有过那样的行为。我是说，也许我在高中打网球之类的时候会有好胜心，但绝不会到为了某件我根本不在乎的事情而想跟别人打架的地步，那太诡异了。是的，我的意思是，你不仅不是红袜队球迷，你甚至都不是棒球迷或体育迷。
And the idea that within 10 minutes, you're trying to defend the honor of Red Sox Nation, it's kind of insane. The Red Sox Nation and my mother. Let me take you back to another time earlier in your life, Meena, that foreshadowed this unexpected transformation. And arguably, this earlier situation had much higher stakes than a baseball game. Your parents are from the war-torn region that was once known as Yugoslavia,
而在10分钟内，你竟然试图捍卫“红袜国”的荣誉，这简直有点疯狂。红袜国和我母亲的荣誉。米娜，让我带你回到你生命中更早的另一个时期，那次经历预示了这种意料之外的转变。而且可以说，早期那次情况的利害关系远比一场棒球比赛重大得多。你的父母来自曾被称为南斯拉夫的饱受战争蹂躏的地区，
your mother is Bosnia, your father is Serbian. You grew up in the United States, but you had some exposure to the events happening in your parents' homeland. How did you hear about those events? Well, once tensions started escalating in the Balkans, you know, there was quite a bit of news coverage. And so because we still have many family members at that point in the former, what was then called Yugoslavia, you know, the news was on all the time. My parents were in contact with various relatives who were still over there, you know, we were trying to figure out whether or not there was anything to be done,
你的母亲是波斯尼亚人，你的父亲是塞尔维亚人。你在美国长大，但你对父母故乡发生的事件有所耳闻。你是怎么听说这些事情的？嗯，一旦巴尔干地区的紧张局势开始升级，你知道的，就有相当多的新闻报道。而且因为当时我们在前南斯拉夫（当时被称为南斯拉夫）还有很多亲戚，所以新闻一直在播。我的父母与那些还在那里的各种亲戚保持着联系，你知道的，我们在试图弄清楚是否有什事情可做，
did people want to stay, did people want to leave. But what we were seeing was that the situations were getting worse. And I remember one particular day, my mom noting, they're putting logs across the major highways that connect the different regions to one another. And I didn't understand what that meant. And she said, they're trying to build the borders. They're making passage between them impossible. And she said, now it trying to build the borders. They're making passage between them impossible. And she said, now it's time to get worried.
人们是想留下来，还是想离开。但我们看到的情况是局势越来越糟。我记得有一次，我妈妈指出：“他们在连接不同地区的主干公路上横放圆木。”我不明白那是什么意思。她说：“他们在试图建立边界。他们在切断地区之间的通行。”她接着说：“现在是该担心的时候了。”
I understand there were times when you would have relatives, essentially fleeing Yugoslavia who would stay with you for periods of time. That's right. So the first family members who came over were actually my mother's sister, my aunt, her husband and their three sons, my cousins. And the reason that they left was because our family is, I mean, it's mixed in the same way that Bosnia itself is mixed. So my mom and her sister were born in Macedonia,
据我所知，有时你的亲戚基本上是逃离南斯拉夫，并在你们家寄住一段时间。没错。所以第一批过来的亲戚其实是我母亲的妹妹、我的阿姨、她的丈夫以及他们的三个儿子，也就是我的表兄弟们。他们离开的原因是我们的家庭，我的意思是，它就像波斯尼亚本身一样是混居的。所以我的妈妈和她的阿姨出生在马其顿，
but they grew up in Bosnia, their whole lives. Their father was born in Montenegro, and so they have Serbian names. Later on in her life, my aunt married a Muslim man, and all three of their children have Muslim names, and so her last name now is Muslim. And so at that time, you have Bosnia and sort of from both sides, Serbian forces
但她们一生都在波斯尼亚长大。她们的父亲出生在黑山，所以她们有塞尔维亚名字。后来在生活中，我的阿姨嫁给了一个穆斯林男子，他们的三个孩子都有穆斯林名字，所以她现在的姓氏也是穆斯林姓氏。因此，在那个时候，你有波斯尼亚，从双方来看，有塞尔维亚军队
and Croatian powers and coaching, seeking to sort of control the region, to claim more power. And the people who are sort of left in the middle, in particular, who have no power, are the Muslim population. And so my aunt has three Muslim children, and her husband is Muslim, and she has a Serbian name, and it's a really complicated situation and One of the things that shocked her and shocked my mother was that she started to talk to
和克罗地亚势力在推波助澜，寻求控制该地区以获取更多权力。而那些被抛在中间、尤其是毫无权力的群体，就是穆斯林人口。所以我的阿姨有三个穆斯林孩子，她的丈夫也是穆斯林，而她自己却有一个塞尔维亚名字，这是一个非常复杂的情况。最让她和我的母亲感到震惊的事情之一是，她开始与
neighbors of hers who had either sort of Serbian heritage or Croatian heritage, but also identified as Bosnian up until this point saying You know, what do we get to do? things seem to be getting worse. We aren't sure we're safe here and Much to her surprise rather than rallying around them, these friends of hers who she'd known since before high school, who had raised her children with her, said, yeah, you need to leave. There isn't room for you here anymore. Now, they were not saying you need to leave with a view of saying,
她的邻居交谈，这些人要么有塞尔维亚血统，要么有克罗地亚血统，但到目前为止他们也一直认为自己是波斯尼亚人。她对他们说：“你知道的，我们该怎么办？情况看起来越来越糟了。我们不确定在这里是否安全。”令她惊讶的是，这些她从高中前就认识、曾同她一起抚养孩子的朋友们，不但没有团结在他们身边支持他们，反而说：“是的，你们需要离开。这里已经没有你们的容身之地了。”现在，他们说“你们需要离开”并不是出于
we're looking out for your safety. You know, we think it would be wiser if you left. This was more than that. This was you no longer have a home here. And how did your aunt react to this? I mean, what did it feel like to have people who had, you know, she had broken bread with, who, you know, they'd raised children together with played in, you know, who raised children together, played in the kids, played together in the neighborhood streets.
“我们在关心你们的安全，我们认为你们离开会更明智”这种角度。这超越了那一层含义。这意思是——你们在这里再也没有家了。你的阿姨对此有何反应？当那些曾与她分享过面包、共同抚养过孩子、在街区街道上一起玩耍的人，
What did it feel like to have neighbor turn on neighbor? I think she was terrified. I think that most of us don't expect that the people who we would count as our closest and dearest friends, almost family, could say to us, you know, following political events that they don't want us around anymore, because we are not part of them. We don't belong to their group. We're no longer welcome here. Now, I know this has very different stakes from what happened at the baseball game, but it
当邻居反目成仇时，她是什么感觉？我想她吓坏了。我想我们大多数人都不会料到，那些被我们视为最亲密、最挚爱、亲如家人的人，会在政治事件发生后对我们说，他们不再想要我们在附近了，因为我们不属于他们。我们不属于他们的群体。我们不再受欢迎了。现在，我知道这与棒球比赛中发生的事情有着截然不同的利害关系，但
is interesting to see some of the same dynamics at play. It's almost as if, you know, in a moment, people were being swept up in the fervor of those around them and were getting transformed. That's exactly right. And that's one of the things that I find most terrifying, but also most interesting about group dynamics is how quickly they shift. Have you given, I mean, I think you've talked in the past about this idea that people have explored, which is that the line between, you know, who we think we are most of the time
看到其中发挥作用的某些相同动态还是很有趣的。这几乎就像是，人们在一瞬间被周围人的狂热情绪所吞没并发生了转变。完全正确。这也是我对群体动力学感到最可怕、但也最有趣的地方之一，那就是它们的转变速度有多快。你有没有想过——我想你过去曾谈过人们探讨过的一个观点，那就是我们认为的大多数时候的自我
and who we can become, that line is actually much thinner than many of us imagine. It's funny you say that because often when I speak with folks and I tell them a little bit about what it is that I do, what my research is about, I'll ask them questions like, you know, when was the last time you punch someone? And most of the time the answer is, well, never. And when was the last time you saw someone punch someone else that wasn't part of a sporting event, for example? And most of the time the answer is, well, never.
与我们可能成为的自我之间的界限，其实比我们想象的要薄得多。真好笑你这么说，因为每当我跟别人交谈，向他们讲述一些我的工作、我的研究内容时，我会问他们一些问题，比如：“你上一次揍别人是什么时候？”大多数时候答案都是：“嗯，从来没有。”“你上一次看到别人揍人（比如不是在体育赛事中）是什么时候？”大多数时候答案都是：“嗯，从来没有。”
And it reveals that in our day to day lives, we have these strong moral prohibitions against harm that guide most of our behaviors most of the time. But all of that seems to go out the window when the gravitational pull of groups exerts its force. When it starts to align people within groups and align against each other between groups that that behavior changes. When we think of ourselves, we usually think of ourselves as individuals.
这表明在我们的日常生活中，我们有着强烈的反对伤害他人的道德禁忌，这些禁忌在大多数时候指导着我们的绝大多数行为。但当群体的引力发挥作用时，这一切似乎都烟消云散了。当它开始在群体内部将人们凝聚在一起，并在群体之间彼此对立时，这种行为就发生了改变。当我们审视自己时，我们通常认为自己是独立的个体。
We say, I'm a cautious person or I'm a bold person. Few of us stop to ask whether we are still the same person when we are in the grip of a crowd. We imagine we will always be the same person when we are in the grip of a crowd. We imagine we will always be the same people we always were. This is why when we hear accounts of decent people being swept up into mobs we tell ourselves that would never happen to me. I don't have it in me to become a looter, a vandal, to hurt someone. When we come back, what happens in the brain when me and you get transformed into us and them? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
我们说，我是个谨慎的人，或者我是个勇敢的人。很少有人会停下来问问自己：当我们身处人群的掌控之中时，我们还是不是同一个人。我们想象自己无论何时都永远是过去的那个自己。这就是为什么当我们听到正派的人被卷入暴民之中的故事时，我们会告诉自己：“这种事永远不会发生在我身上。我可没有当暴徒、搞破坏或伤害别人的基因。”稍后回来，当我和你被转化为“我们”和“他们”时，大脑究竟发生了什么？欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Meena Chikara studies how the groups around us shape our thoughts, feelings, and behavior. Growing up, Mina held stories of how in her parents' former homeland of Yugoslavia, neighbors turned on neighbors, friends, on friends. Mina herself, in situations with much smaller stakes, has been surprised at the effects that groups have on her. Mina, all of us recognize that we are simultaneously individuals and members of groups. You are the individual Mina Chikara, but you're also part of the group of people who work at Harvard University, you're part of the group of people who identify as psychologists. So we carry around these different identities inside us. Why do different situations activate different aspects of our identity?
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔。心理学家米娜·奇卡拉研究我们身边的群体如何塑造我们的思想、感受和行为。在成长过程中，米娜听过许多关于在她父母的故乡南斯拉夫，邻居与邻居反目、朋友与朋友成仇的故事。而在利害关系小得多的情况下，米娜自己也曾对群体对她产生的影响感到惊讶。米娜，我们所有人都意识到，我们既是独立的个体，也是群体的成员。你是个体米娜·奇卡拉，但你也是哈佛大学教职工群体的一部分，你也是认同自己是心理学家的人群的一部分。所以我们的内心里携带著这些不同的身份。为什么不同的情境会激活我们身份的不同方面？
That's a really interesting question. And what's actually fascinating to me about this is that it's highly context dependent. So who your most salient self is can change as you walk from one room into another one. And so thinking about folks who might be listening to this, they drop off their kids at school.
这是一个非常有趣的问题。对我而言，真正迷人的是，这高度取决于语境。因此，当你从一个房间走到另一个房间时，你身上最突出的那个“自我”是会发生改变的。想想那些可能在听这个节目的人，他们把孩子送到学校，
And that's when their parents, but that car door closes, or they walk away from the school and suddenly they're in work mode and they're, you know, part of their organization. And they get into the organization and then maybe they're part of a more specific team within that organization and so on and so forth.
那一刻他们是父母，但车门一关，或者他们离开学校，突然之间他们就进入了工作模式，成为了他们组织的一部分。他们进入组织后，也许他们又成为了该组织中某个更具体团队的一部分，诸如此类。
And so, what's so interesting about it is that it starts to speak to the dynamism that we were talking about before. It's really, really flexible process which pieces of us get highlighted within any given context. Hmm. So one of the ways in which aspects of our identity are made salient is when we find ourselves among the few people in a group who have that identity. So New Yorkers might not look twice at other New Yorkers in New York,
所以，这最有趣的地方在于，它印证了我们之前讨论过的动态性。哪一部分的自己会在任何特定的语境中被突显出来，这是一个非常非常灵活的过程。嗯。因此，突显我们身份特征的途径之一，就是当我们发现自己是群体中少数拥有该身份的人时。纽约人走在纽约可能不会对其他纽约人多看一眼，
but put two New Yorkers together in Zimbabwe, and all of a sudden they realize they have a lot in common. I understand there have been times you've been to scientific conferences where you've realized that you're one of the few women around and that changes how you're thinking about gender in the context of the scientific meeting. That's exactly right. And there are a couple things that happen here. One is that your own identity becomes salient to you.
但把两个纽约人放在津巴布韦，他们突然就会发现彼此有很多共同点。据我所知，你有时去参加科学会议时，会发现自己是周围为数不多的女性之一，这会改变你在科学会议这个语境下对性别的思考方式。完全正确。这里会发生几件事。首先，你自己的身份对你来说变得格外显著。
Another possibility is that the other folks in the room start to treat you in line with that identity more than they might have had you not been the minority in that case, right? So just coming back to the Yankees Red Sox, part of what makes your identity salient as a Red Sox fan and Yankees stadium is that you're in the minority. But the other part is how other Yankees fans treat you, right? So when there's a clear power differential
另一种可能是，房间里的其他人开始按照那种身份来对待你，这种对待的程度可能会超过你并非该少数群体时的情况，对吧？所以回到扬基队与红袜队的例子，作为红袜队球迷，你的身份在扬基体育场变得显著的部分原因在于你是少数派。但另一部分原因在于扬基队球迷是如何对待你的，对吧？所以当存在明显的权力差异
or dynamic at play, that really sort of heightens the stakes and makes these kinds of identities more salient. So in my day to day life, my identity as a woman is not particularly salient to me. But when at a scientific conference, for example, if I'm one of two or three people in the room who happened to share that identity suddenly becomes a bit activated for me. Because I recognize that I'm in the minority. And there are all sorts of inferences that start to pop up, you know, am I Recognize as a legitimate member of the community in this room? Are my contributions equally valued?
或动态作用时，这确实会提高利害关系，并使这类身份更加显著。所以在我的日常生活中，我作为女性的身份对我来说并不是特别显著。但在科学会议上，例如，如果我是房间里仅有的两三个共享该身份的人之一，它对我来说突然就被激活了。因为我意识到我是少数派。并且所有各种各样的推论也开始涌现，你知道的，我
It starts to raise questions that wouldn't otherwise come up if I didn't feel that sort of minority status Mm-hmm And with the example that you gave me about your family history in Yugoslavia, presumably one of the other markers has to do with access to resources, who gets what, and especially in a situation of competition, our group identities can become especially salient to us. Yes, absolutely. When there's a zero-sum situation, when there's some resource at stake, and there's overt competition between two sets of people, two collectives, then identity is incredibly important because that is a boundary
在这个房间里是否被认为是一个合法的社群成员？我的贡献是否得到了同等的重视？它开始引发一些问题，如果我没有感受到那种少数群体地位的话，这些问题是不会出现的。嗯。根据你向我讲述的关于你在南斯拉夫的家族历史的例子，另一个标志大概与资源获取有关，谁能得到什么，尤其是在竞争的情况下，我们的群体身份对我们来说会变得尤为显著。是的，绝对如此。当出现零和博弈的情况，当有某种资源处于危险之中，并且两组人、两个集体之间存在公开竞争时，身份认同就变得极其重要，因为那是一个
along which competition arises and people will start to, you know, potentially engage in less than pro-social or outright anti-social behavior towards one another because there's some resources to stake. In competitive situations, people don't just become watchful about other groups. They start to police the boundaries of their own groups. They start making ever finer distinctions between who should be a member and who should not. Many people have studied something called the over exclusion bias, which is when people will sort of draw tighter boundaries around who counts as us when things get competitive
竞争由此产生的边界，人们可能会开始（潜在地）做出对彼此不利的或彻底反社会的行为，因为有某些资源危在旦夕。在竞争情境中，人们不仅对其他群体保持警惕，他们还开始整顿自己群体的边界。他们开始对谁应该成为成员、谁不应该成为成员做出越来越精细的区分。许多人研究过一种被称为“过度排斥偏见”的现象，也就是当情况变得具有竞争性
or he did. And so one particularly remarkable example of this work to me is work that's been done by Amy Crush, who's a faculty member at Cornell and a collaborator. She's found that when you prime participants, white participants with economic scarcity, they actually see faces as blacker relative to when they've not been primed with that kind of scarcity. So basically the threshold at which someone is deemed white gets higher and higher and higher, it's less likely for them to categorize somebody as white when they've
或充满敌意时，人们会在“谁算作我们自己”周围划定更严密的边界。对我而言，这项研究中一个特别显著的例子是康奈尔大学教员兼合作者艾米·克鲁什（Amy Cuddy）所做的工作。她发现，当你用经济稀缺性来对白人参与者进行启动（prime）时，与没有被灌输这种稀缺性的人相比，他们实际上会把面孔看得更黑。基本上，一个人被视为白人的门槛变得越来越高，当他们
been primed with economic scarcity. It's worth pausing for a moment on this finding. White volunteers who were reminded of economic scarcity were less likely to see a face as white than they were when they were not primed to think about scarce economic resources. Their brains instinctively narrowed the definition of who they considered one of us. Competitive group situations can lead to other dramatic responses in our brains. Mina says they can affect how we perceive the emotional states of in-group and out-group members. This was some work that we did with just teams here with green shirts and blue shirts, and
被灌输了经济稀缺性之后，他们将某人归类为白人的可能性就会降低。这个发现值得我们暂停片刻来思考一下。被唤起经济稀缺性记忆的白人志愿者，比那些没有被引导去思考稀缺经济资源的人，更不容易将一张脸视为白人。他们的本能大脑缩小了他们认为属于“我们自己人”的定义范围。竞争性的群体情境会导致我们大脑做出其他戏剧性的反应。米娜表示，它们会影响我们如何感知内群体和外群体成员的情绪状态。这是我们针对仅带有绿衬衫和蓝衬衫的团队所做的一些工作，
we were interested in whether or not people perceived the emotions in faces, in static images of faces differently depending on whether it was an in-group or an out-group member. What was really interesting to us was, you know, we thought that people would just be sort of more accurate in their judgments of in-group faces relative to out-group faces. So when an in-group face was happy that you would be more likely to say that that face is happy relative to not, and when it was angry that you would be more likely to say that it's angry relative to not, and what we found was that there was actually a generalized positivity bias, which is to say that
我们感兴趣的是，人们在静态面孔图像中感知面孔情绪时，是否会根据对方是内群体成员还是外群体成员而有所不同。让我们感到非常有趣的是，我们原本以为人们在对内群体面孔的判断上会比对外群体面孔更准确。因此，当内群体面孔表现出快乐时，你会更有可能说那张脸是快乐的（相比于不说时）；当它表现出愤怒时，你会更有可能说它是愤怒的。而我们发现的却是，实际上存在一种普遍的积极性偏差，也就是说，
when people saw in-group faces, it didn't matter if they were happy or angry. People just said they were more positive than when they were looking at out-group faces. And what's remarkable about studies like this, but this is not the only example of it, is that these groups are in some ways artificially constructed. These are not pre-existing groups that the volunteers had coming into the lab, right? That's exactly right. We show them a picture of 24 people, 12 are in the BluShirt team, they two are in the BluShirt team, the other 12 are in the green team. We give them a little memory test to make sure they remember which team each person is
当人们看到内群体面孔时，不管它们是快乐还是愤怒，人们只是说它们比看着外群体面孔时更具积极性。像这样的研究引人注目之处（而且这并不是唯一的例子）在于，这些群体在某种程度上是人为构建的。这些并不是志愿者进入实验室时就预先存在的群体，对吧？完全正确。我们给他们看一张24人的照片，其中12人是蓝衬衫团队成员，另12人是绿团队成员。我们给他们做一个小型记忆测试，以确保他们记住每个人属于哪个团队。
on. Then we just start to show them pictures of those folks expressing either angry or joyful emotions. I mean, it's remarkable that if a simple manipulation like that in the lab can have measurable effects, obviously, you know, if we spend years or decades being, you know, inculcated with all of the norms and attitudes and beliefs of our groups, we learn about their histories and cultures and uniqueness, it's hardly surprising in some ways that the groups can have really powerful effects on us on our behavior and the way we think. That's exactly right. And as an extension, a real world and more consequential extension, I have colleagues like Guero Dunham et Gale, who've found that, for example, white participants' rate black faces is angrier than white faces, for example. Now, that could be stereotype driven with specifically stereotypes associated with black Americans within the United States, but it could also be a manifestation of this
然后我们开始向他们展示这些人表达愤怒或快乐情绪的照片。请注意，如果实验室里这样一个简单的操纵就能产生可测量的效果，那么显而易见，如果我们花数年或数十年来接受我们群体的所有规范、态度和信仰的熏陶，了解他们的历史、文化和独特性，那么从某些方面来看，群体能够对我们的行为和思维方式产生非常强大的影响也就不足为奇了。完全正确。作为延伸，一个现实世界中影响更深远的延伸，我有像格雷罗·邓纳姆（Guero Dunham）和盖尔（Gale）这样的同事，他们发现例如白人参与者将黑人面孔评定为比白人面孔更具愤怒感。这可能是刻板印象驱动的，具体与美国国内对非裔美国人的刻板印象有关，但它也可能是这种
more general positivity bias, which is that we just see out group members in general as expressing more negative emotions. They've been worked by the research of J. Van Bevel whom we've previously had on Hidden Brain, looking at how we perceive the distance that opponents or enemies have to us. And some of this work actually looks at Yankees and Red Sox fans, and looks how closely people perceive their enemies are. Can you tell me about that work, the ways in which our brains might misperceive the distance between us and our opponents under situations of stress or enmity.
更普遍的积极性偏差的一种表现，也就是我们普遍认为外群体成员表达了更多的负面情绪。我们曾做过J·范·贝韦尔（J. Van Bavel）研究的工作，我们之前在《隐藏的大脑》中采访过他，他研究了我们如何感知对手或敌人与我们的距离。其中一些工作实际上着眼于扬基队和红袜队的球迷，并观察人们如何感知他们的敌人有多近。你能跟我讲讲这项研究吗？即在压力或敌意情境下，我们的大脑可能会如何错误感知我们与对手之间的距离。
The finding is that people will judge the distance of sort of competitor or, you know, threatening out group members' institutions as closer than they actually are. So for example, if you're Yankees fan, you judge Fenway as being much closer than it actually is. That's the Red Sox stadium in Boston, relative to how far away you judge the Orioles in Maryland, right, in Baltimore. And so, you know, the idea is that one possibility is that when you start to have these really competitive inner group contexts, we're sort of primed with the notion of, well, this side represents a threat,
研究结果是，人们会判断竞争对手或具有威胁性的外群体成员机构的距离比实际距离更近。例如，如果你是扬基队的球迷，你会认为芬威球场比它实际上的距离要近得多。（那是波斯顿的红袜队主场），相比之下，你判断马里兰州（巴尔的摩）的金莺队距离有多远时则不同。所以，这个想法的可能性之一是，当你开始拥有这些竞争激烈的内群体环境时，我们的脑海中就被植入了这样一种概念：这一方构成了威胁，
we have to be prepared for it, we need to engage. And so we may trick ourselves into thinking that they're actually nearer than they are. And in another version of that same study, I understand that J. and its colleagues found that, people who were concerned about Mexican immigration to the United States, for example, perceive the Mexican border as being physically closer to them than it actually was, which I think is another variation
我们必须为此做好准备，我们需要参与其中。因此，我们可能会欺骗自己，认为他们实际上比现实中更近。在同一项研究的另一个版本中，据我所知，J及其同事发现，例如，关心墨西哥移民进入美国的那些人，会认为墨西哥边境在物理距离上比实际距离更离他们更近，我认为这是你刚才给我的扬基-红袜队例子的另一个变体。没错，我的意思是，这当然是一个影响深远得多的例子。米娜发现，竞争情境会突显我们的群体身份，但她也发现了竞争与群体之间关系的另一个有趣方面。有时，仅仅把人分成小组就会增加他们对竞争的感知。
of the Yankees Red Sox example you just gave me. That's right, I mean, and certainly a much more consequential one. Mina has found that competitive situations accentuate our group identities, but she's also identified another intriguing aspect of the relationship between competition and groups. Sometimes simply putting people into groups increases their perception of competition.
每当我想到这一点，总是让我感到震撼。只要你把人们分门别类成不同的群体，他们就已经感知到了竞争。即便你并没有将竞争作为这两个群体之间关系的本质摆在台面上。所以你只要把三个人放进这个房间，三个人放进那个房间，仅仅因为被拆分成这两组人，人们就会——你知道的，他们对待自己房间里的人会比对待走廊对面的那些人更大方。
This is something that always blows my mind when I think about it. The second you sort people into groups, they already perceive competition. Even when you haven't put competition on the table as the nature of the relationship between those two groups. So you just put three people in this room, three people in that room, and just by virtue of being split up into those two sets of people, people are sort of, you know, they're more generous with the folks in their room than they are with the folks who are across the hallway.
尽管你完全有可能最终进入对面的房间，对吧？当人们作为一个群体共同做出判断时，他们比独自做出判断时，更有可能指派无辜的他人去喝更辣、更痛苦的辣酱。成为群体的一员似乎会启动竞争，以及地平线上存在某种威胁的感知，从而引发这类行为。我的意思是，这
Even though you could very well have ended up in the opposite broom, right? People are more likely to assign innocent others to drink more painfully hot hot sauce when they make that judgment together as a group relative to when they make that judgment alone. Being a member of a group seems to prime competition and the perception that there is some sort of threat on the horizon that that engenders these kinds of behaviors. I mean this
几乎让我想起了我在初中和高中的日子，当时你在运动场上被分成不同的队伍，有红队或蓝队。突然之间，这些划分非常随机，但在几分钟内，它们就开始变得意义重大。你对红队产生所有的忠诚，对蓝队产生所有的敌意。而30秒前这些通通不存在。
almost takes me back to my days in middle school and high school where you get divided into teams on the sports field and you have the red team or the blue team. And suddenly, these divisions are really random, but within minutes, they start to feel consequential. And you have all these allegiances to the red team, and all these antagonisms towards the blue team. And none of that existed 30 seconds ago.
我认为，这就是当你开始将人群划分成群体时被激活的图式（schema）的一部分，即便这些群体没有任何意义，你的脑海中也存在这样一个模板，它在说：当我们分成小组时，通常是因为我们要互相竞争。这其中附带着一大堆关联，而这些关联可能对当前的情境根本没有任何意义。因此，当我们认同自己是群体成员或者识别出其他人是其他群体的成员时，我们的思维方式显然在发生改变，
And I think that that's part of what the schema is that gets activated when you start to cleave people into groups, even when those groups have no meaning, is that there's just a template in your head that says, well, when we break up into groups, it's usually because we're going to compete with one another. There's a whole bunch of associations that come with that that may not actually make any sense for the current context. So the ways in which we think are clearly changing when we identify as members of the group or we identify other people who are members of other groups,
但我们的情感也经历着转变。其中一种经历转变的情感就是同理心。你能为我们描述一下“狭隘同理心”（parochial empathy）这个词的含义吗？当然。所以我的意思是，描述一下我们对同理心的理解可能很有价值，因为它是一个饱含感情色彩的词。但当我们思考它时，我们通常将其视为与另一个人建立连接的情感部分。也就是说，要么为他们感同身受，要么对发生在他们身上的事情感到难过，例如。所以狭隘同理心指的是这样一种现象：对于那些在我们群体之外的人，我们不会感到那么难过。所以在某些情况下，我们甚至可能毫无感觉，我们感受到的是冷漠。
but our feelings also undergo a transformation too. And one of the feelings that undergoes a transformation is the feeling of empathy. Can you describe for us what's meant by the term parochial empathy? Sure. So I mean, it might be worth describing, but we even mean my empathy, because it's kind of a loaded term. But when we think about it, we sort of mean it to be the feeling part of connecting with another person. So either feeling for them or feeling bad about something that happened to them, for example. So parochial empathy refers to the phenomenon where we don't feel quite as bad for those folks who lie outside of our own groups. And so in some cases we may even feel nothing at all, we feel apathy.
当然，对另一个群体的遭遇感到冷漠，到积极地从中获得快乐，只有一步之遥。我们经常对公开表达幸灾乐祸（Schadenfreude）的行为皱眉头。但米娜表示，在某些领域，幸灾乐祸是社会可以接受的。这些竞争情境有趣的地方在于，当另一个人发生坏事而你感到快乐时，
Of course, it's a short step from feeling apathy at another group's misfortune to actively taking pleasure in it. We often frown upon open expressions of Shadden Freude. But Mina says there are domains where Shadden Freude is socially acceptable. What's interesting about these competitive situations is that when a bad thing happens to another person and you feel pleasure, It's solely through the channel of your group identities. I only feel good about this bad thing happening to you because you represent this other team. And most people don't like expressing this.
这完全是通过你的群体身份这一渠道产生的。我之所以为这件坏事的发生感到高兴，仅仅是因为你代表了另一个团队。大多数人并不喜欢表达这一点。
And from very young ages we're told, you're not supposed to laugh at other people when they get hurt, you're not supposed to feel good when bad things happen to other people. So what are the scenarios where it can be socially acceptable hurt you're not supposed to feel good when bad things happen to other people. So what are the scenarios where it can be socially acceptable to express pleasure at someone else's pain, bitter political battles, and intense sports competitions? In sports I think it's a safe place to express competitive and sort of, you know, hostile beliefs
从小到大，我们都被教导说：当别人受伤时，你不应该嘲笑他们；当别人遭遇坏事时，你不应该感到高兴。那么，在哪些场景下，公开对别人的痛苦表示高兴是可以被社会接受的呢？比如激烈的政治斗争和紧张的体育竞赛？在体育运动中，我认为这是一个表达竞争性以及某种敌对信仰和感受的安全场所。
and feelings. It's sanctioned, you know, it's explicit that it's a competition. So it's not so taboo. And because politics has become more like a competition or more like a war. And so now that sort of opened it up, the norms have shifted so that it's okay, and even encouraged by some people that you should express overt pleasure when the other side suffers or when the other side loses or on the other side makes an error. Mina has found that in domains where it is not socially acceptable to openly display
这是被认可的，你知道的，比赛是公开明确的。所以这并不是那么禁忌。而且因为政治变得越来越像一场竞争，或者更像是一场战争。所以现在这种情况在某种程度上被放开了，社会规范已经发生了转变，以至于这样做是可以接受的，甚至受到一些人的鼓励：当另一方遭受痛苦、另一方失败或另一方犯错时，你应该表达出明显的快感。米娜发现，在那些公开表现出幸灾乐祸在社会上不可接受的领域
Schadenfreude to where opposing groups, people still engage in it secretly. In one experiment, she presented volunteers with accounts of negative things happening to groups that they admired or respected, like firefighters, or groups that they envied or disliked, like investment bankers. And what we did was we actually measured how much they smiled by something called facial electromiography. And this is where we put sensors all over the face to try to pick up measured how much they smiled by something called facial electromiography. And this is where we put sensors all over the face
对于对立的群体，人们仍然会私下进行这种行为。在一项实验中，她向志愿者展示了一些关于负面事情发生在她所钦佩或尊敬的群体（如消防员）身上的描述，或者是他们嫉妒或厌恶的群体（如投资银行家）。我们所做的实际上是通过一种叫做面部肌电图的技术来测量他们笑了多少。这是一种我们在脸上放置传感器的技术，试图捕捉到通过面部肌电图测量他们微笑程度的方法，我们把传感器贴在脸上
to try to pick up on tiny muscle movements that are happening within the face, that track with reported and experienced emotion. And so what we found is that people's cheeks got pulled into a smile more when negative events befell folks, like investment bankers, relative to when they befell folks like, you know, an elderly man or a firefighter. So researchers have also found that some people identify
试图捕捉面部发生的微小肌肉运动，这些运动与报告和经历的情绪相吻合。因此，我们发现，当负面事件降临到投资银行家这样的人身上时，人们的嘴角会更多地牵动成微笑，而相比之下，当这些事件降临到像老人或消防员这样的人身上时则不然。因此，研究人员还发现，有些人对自己的群体有着强烈的认同感
so strongly with their groups that they experience shot and fraud in situations that are not only bad for the out group, but potentially bad for members of the in group. So Richard Smith and his colleagues have conducted studies looking at political partisans in the United States who heard bad news about an overseas war or the economy. Are you familiar with this work, Mina? Can you tell me what they found? Yes, I love this paper. And so say I'm a Democrat. If I hear that the Republicans have made a
以至于他们在不仅对外群体不利、而且可能对内群体成员也不利的处境中也会体验到幸灾乐祸。因此，理查德·史密斯和他的同事们进行了一些研究，观察美国那些听到海外战争或经济方面坏消息的政治党派人士。你熟悉这项工作吗，米娜？你能告诉我他们发现了什么吗？是的，我很喜欢这篇论文。所以，假设我是一个民主党人。如果我听说共和党人做出了一个影响经济的政治决定，并且导致全社会的经济崩溃，我仍然会感到高兴，尽管这给我带来了糟糕的物质结果。或者，作为一个共和党人，我听说民主党人选择参与一场战争或伤害另一个国家。我们发现的是，我们失去了自己的军队。我依然报告说自己感到一些高兴
political decision that affects the economy and it tanks the economy for everybody, I still experience pleasure despite the fact that there are bad material outcomes for me. Or if as a Republican, I hear that Democrats have made a choice to engage in a war or to hurt another country. And what we find is that we lose our own troops. I still report feeling some pleasure
尽管有人为了这个选择而丧生。我认为这开始触及我们今天政治系统面临的最大挑战之一，那就是：过去被称为协调游戏的事情，现在已经被框定为一场战争。当各个群体认为自己陷入了一场生死之战时，这便赋予了他们几乎可以做任何事情来伤害对手的许可证。这或许可以解释为什么在许多国家的整个政治谱系中，人们总是用战争的语言来描述他们与对手之间的政策分歧。
despite the fact that people have died for that choice. I think it starts to speak to one of the greatest challenges that are facing our political system today, which is that what used to be framed as a game of coordination has now been framed as a war. When groups think of themselves as locked in battle, it gives them license to do almost anything to harm their opponents. This may be one reason why, across the political spectrum in many countries, people describe the policy disagreements they have with their opponents using the language of war.
政治中最具挑战性的事情之一是，每一方都有他们试图保护的一群边缘化人群，对吧？无论是被关在笼子里我们边境上的婴儿，还是他们担心被“诱导洗脑”的儿童。每个人都确信对方正在发动攻击，我们再次陷入了这种战争状态。而让这一切如此强大且危险的原因在于，在自卫的过程中，几乎没有什么是不道德的。
One of the things that's so challenging about politics is that each side has sets of marginalized people that they seek to protect, right? Whether it's babies on our border who are being kept in cages, whether it's the children that they're worried about being groomed. Everybody is certain that the other side is on the attack, that again, we are in this war situation. And what makes that so powerful and so dangerous is that there is very little that is not morally acceptable in self-defense.
所以如果你的所作所为仅仅是为了保护自己和这些人，没有人会怪你。现在一切皆有可能了。因此，你在民调数据中看到，随着时间推移，人们对民主倒退的支持度不断增加，人们更有可能支持那些为了赢得胜利而弯曲规则的候选人，诸如此类，也就不足为奇了。所以，你知道，这是一个非常非常复杂和危险的局面，因为每个人都觉得自己这么做
So nobody will fault you if all you're doing is protecting yourself in these people. Anything is on the table now. And so it's not surprising, then, that you see, for example, in polling data, that you're seeing increased support over time for democratic backsliding that people are more likely to support candidates who would bend the rules in order to be able to win and so on and so forth. So, you know, it's a very, very complicated and dangerous situation because everybody feels like they're
是为了其他人，是为了自卫。我的意思是，你在这里提出的一个有趣的问题是，在某些方面，当我们审视人们的行为，尤其是来自其他群体的行为时，我们会说：他们怎么可能做出如此错误的事情？我想我们没有看到的是，他们并不觉得自己做的事是错的。他们认为自己的所作所为是道德上正义的，他们基本上相信自己是在为某种事物挺身而出，他们实际上是在履行道德的使命，他们实际上是在履行道德的使命。
doing it for other people and they're doing it for self-defense. I mean, the interesting thing that you're raising here is in some ways when we look at the behavior of people, especially people from other groups, and we say, how in the world could they be doing something that is so wrong? I think what we're failing to see is that they're not seeing what they're doing is wrong. They're seeing is what they're doing as morally righteous, that they're basically believing that standing up for something they're actually acting in the service of morality, they're actually acting in the service of morality. As opposed to acting in the service of immorality, it's a positive thing, it's not a negative thing, even in the minds of our opponents.
而不是在履行不道德的使命，这是一件积极的事情，而不是消极的事情，甚至在我们的对手心中也是如此。通常情况下，当我们为了某种事业而战、当我们支持某种内群体仪式、或者当我们试图增强对群体的忠诚度等等时，往往是我们最具暴力的时候。人们做出一些最糟糕的事情，正是因为他们觉得自己这样做是正义的。
Often we are at our most violent when we are doing it for a cause, or when we are supporting an in-group ritual, or when we are trying to increase loyalty to the group and so on and so forth. People do some of the worst things they do because they think they're being righteous in doing it. There have been times that you yourself have felt this intoxicating sense of righteousness. When you were a new mom, you became very upset about the separation of parents and children carried out of the southern border by the Trump administration.
有时候，你自己也曾感受到这种令人陶醉的正义感。当你成为一个新手妈妈时，你对特朗普政府在南部边境实施的父母与儿童分离政策感到非常愤怒。米娜，告诉我，你的愤怒促使你在社交媒体上做了什么？哦，好吧，这不是我最引以为傲的时刻。事情是这样的，当时我们正在听取关于这方面的报道。当时我好像有一个六个月大的孩子，你知道的，我们看到了很多从美墨边境传出的画面，展示了这些与父母分离的儿童的遭遇，他们不得不呆在
Tell me what your rage prompted you to do, Mina, on social media. Oh, well, this is not my proudest moment. What happened was we were hearing coverage about this. I had a six-month-old at the time, I think, and you know, we were, there was a lot of footage that was coming out of the U.S.-Mexican border sort of showing what it was that was happening to these children who were being separated from their parents and who were, you know, having to stay
在这些条件恶劣的营地里。出于沮丧，我在推特上写道：我希望斯蒂芬·米勒以及所有对这些结果负责的人，在每次入睡时都会被这些孩子的尖叫声惊醒。因为这就是我的感受。作为一个新手妈妈，我的感受就是这样。听到这些婴儿为父母而哭泣，我对边境上这场人道主义悲剧的感受就是这样。
in these, these camps in abominable conditions. And in frustration, I tweeted, I hope that Stephen Miller, and everybody else who's responsible for these outcomes, is woken from every time they fall asleep with the screams of these children. And because that's how I felt. That's how I felt as a new mom. That's how I felt about listening to these babies crying for their parents, it's how I felt about this humanitarian travesty at our border.
有一小部分人表示赞同并点了赞。然后可能在第二天一大早，有人回复说：哇，这真是个健康的反应。这真是个健康的反应。这让我意识到，无论我对当时的局势多么愤怒，我都不需要以这种方式火上浇油，这并不是特别具有建设性的行为，我当时做的事情其实是在寻找其他人来告诉我，他们也同样感到愤怒。我们也有同感。我们打算对此做点什么，这会激发某种集体行动，
And a couple of people sort of agreed and liked it. And then maybe early the next morning, somebody replied to it to say, wow, this is a healthy response. this is a healthy response. And it made me realize that no matter how enraged I was by the situation, that I didn't need to pile on in this manner, that this was not particularly constructive, that what I was doing was sort of looking for other people to tell me that they were this upset too. And that we were this upset too. And that we were going to do something about it, that it would animate some collective action,
这种愤怒的力量将成为变革的催化剂。但事实并非如此。那只是我在发泄。但还有很多其他表达愤怒的方式，比发推特说“我希望这个人余生遭受折磨”更有建设性。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何在不让群体绑架我们心灵的情况下成为群体的一部分。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。米娜·奇卡拉是哈佛大学的心理学家。
that the sort of force of the rage was going to be the catalyst for change. But that's not what that was. That was me venting. But there are a lot of other ways to register your outrage that are more constructive than tweeting I hope this person is tortured for the rest of their life. When we come back how to be part of groups without allowing them to hijack our hearts and our minds. You'll listen to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Meena Chikara is a psychologist at Harvard University.
她的研究发现，当我们对某个群体产生深厚的认同感时，我们就会被席卷整个群体的强烈情感所吞没。这反过来又改变了我们的思维方式、感受方式以及行为方式。米娜·奇卡拉，你曾做过这样一项实验：志愿者们被告知了一个关于一个叫布赖恩的男人的故事，但你给不同组的志愿者提供了关于布赖恩故事的不同版本。
Her research has found that when we identify deeply with a group, we can get swept up by emotions sweeping through the group. This in turn changes the way we think, the way we feel, and the way we behave. Meena Samuierstico, you ran a study where volunteers were told a story about a man named Brian, but you gave different groups of volunteers, different accounts of Brian's story.
你能为我描述一下这些故事吗？所以对于其中一部分参与者，我们给他们讲述了一个关于布赖恩的故事，这个故事非常简单。他的电脑崩溃了，丢失了整整一周的工作。然而，另一组参与者则收到了大量关于布赖恩的个性化信息。首先，我们说布赖恩最近刚结婚，他正期待着孩子的出生，他
Can you describe those stories for me? So for one subset of participants, we gave him a story about Brian, and the story was pretty simple. His computer crashed and he lost a full week of work. The other set of participants, however, received a bunch of individuating information about Brian. So, first we say, Brian was recently married, he's expecting the birth of his child, he's
工作非常努力，这是一份全新工作，他拼命工作，就在他的孩子出生前夕，他的电脑崩溃了，丢失了整整一周的工作。现在至关重要的一点是，布赖恩既可以是内群体成员，也可以是外群体成员。所以我们的问题是，当你对布赖恩唯一的了解就是他的电脑崩溃了时，我们会发现当布赖恩是内群体成员时，人们是否比他是外群体成员时感受到更多的同理心？但另一个更有趣的问题是，那么，当你了解了关于布赖恩的这些其他情况时，群体归属感的重要性是否会降低？
been working really hard, it's a brand new job, he worked furiously and then just before his baby is born, his computer crashed and he lost a full week of work. Now, critically, Brian can either be an in-group member or an out-group member. And so our question was, when the only thing you know about Brian is that is computer crashed, do we see that people feel more empathy when Brian's an in-group member than the out-group member? But the other more interesting question was, well, when you know all these other things about Brian, does group membership matter less?
你发现了什么？答案是肯定的。因此，当我们向人们提供这些关于这些人的背景故事时，我们发现人们对内群体成员与外群体成员感到的同理心之间的差距显著缩小了。我们想知道的另一件事是，为什么会这样？因此，我们在实验结束时给参与者进行了一次突击记忆测试，我们
And what did you find? The answer was yes. So when we gave people these background stories about folks, what we found was that the gap between how much empathy people felt for an in-group versus an out-group member was significantly smaller. And the other thing that we wanted to know was, well, why is this happening? And so we gave participants a surprise memory test at the end of the experiment where we
询问大家，你知道的，你了解了布赖恩，在整个研究过程中你也了解了其他所有人，布赖恩是哪个队的？我们发现，那些得到了这些关于这些角色的丰富叙事的人，对他们属于哪个队的记忆较差。这表明，当我们向他们提供这些叙事时，它在某种程度上削弱了他们对团队归属感编码的深度。当它与所有这些其他信息混合在一起时，它在他们脑海中的分量就减轻了。我想知道，这起作用的一种方式是否是通过使我们对群体认同的思考变得更加复杂
asked people, you know, you learn about Brian, you learn about all these other people throughout the course of this study, which team was Brian on? And what we found was that those folks who had gotten those rich narratives about these characters had poor memory for what team they were on. Suggesting that when we gave them these narratives, it sort of dug away at how deeply they had coded the team membership. It just weighed less in their mind when it was mixed in with all this other information. I'm wondering if one way in which this works is by complicating how we think about group identification
和归属感。所以也许我是红袜队的球迷，你是洋基队的球迷，但如果我把你的注意力吸引到这样一个事实上：我们都是父母，或者我们都对心理学感兴趣，这就提供了一个新的群体认同，它充当了一种对体育群体认同的某种制衡。你认为这在这里可能发挥作用吗？绝对是的。我的意思是，交叉认同在社会心理学中已经使用了几十年，我认为实践者也在使用它，试图弥合人与人之间的分歧。问题是，你知道，如果游戏在后台突然响起，我们可以多快地恢复到那些再次让我们产生对立的认同。你的意思是，这篇论文的洞察力是否适用于现实世界？我们是否有一些方法可以在现实中与人们沟通，让他们以不同的方式思考群体认同？
and membership. So maybe I'm a Red Sox fan and Yori Yankees fan, but if I draw your attention to the fact that we are both parents or we are both interested in psychology, this provides a new group identity that acts as a sort of counterweight to the sports group identity. Do you think that might be a play here? Absolutely. I mean, cross-cutting identities have been used for several decades within social psychology, and I think also practitioners, to try to bridge divides between people. The problem is, you know, how quickly, if the game clicks on in the background, we could revert to those other identities, then again, put us at odds. And what do you mean is the insight from this paper applicable in the real world are the
因此，在不同的群体背景下，已经展开了许多努力。比如我想到了一个名为“和平之种”的精彩项目。我的同事朱莉安娜·施罗德和简·赖森与他们合作过一些工作。他们发现，如果你把以色列和巴勒斯坦的阿拉伯儿童、青少年聚集在一起，让他们参加为期数周的夏令营，并让他们建立关系，这会对他们对另一方的看法产生持久的影响，不仅仅是对
ways in which we can actually communicate to people in the real world to think about that group identities differently? So there have been many efforts that have sort of unfolded over different group context. So I'm thinking, for example, there's this amazing program called Seeds of Peace. And my colleagues, Juliana Schroeder and Jane Ryzen have done some work with them. And they find that if you bring Israeli and Palestinian Arab children together, teens together for summer camp for several weeks and you can get them to build the relationships, it can have long lasting effects on how they feel about the other side, not just each
彼此，而是更广泛地对另一方。现在有许许多多项目都在这样做，特别是在政治分歧的范围内。因此，基本上只是试图让人们进行面对面的对话，以一种比单纯的党派归属更加个性化的方式去了解彼此。这项研究中贯穿着一个共同的主题。如果群体的引力促使我们从群体认同的角度来看待他人，那么解决之道就是寻找各种途径将他人视为个体。我们越能看到人们生活的细节，
other, but the other side more generally. And there are lots and lots of programs that are doing that right now, particularly within the political divide. And so basically just trying to get people to have face-to-face conversations where they get to know one another any more individuated way than just their party membership. There is a common theme that runs through much of this work. If the gravitational pull of groups causes us to see people in terms of their group identities, the solution is to seek out ways to see people in terms of their group identities, the solution is to seek out ways to see people as individuals. The more we can see the details of people's lives, the
他们就越不再仅仅是红袜队球迷或洋基队球迷。他们变成了恰好支持这些运动队的个体，变成了在其认同中拥有许多其他方面的个体。有时，甚至只需想象他人生活的细节，就能停止纯粹从群体认同的角度来看待他们，这也会有所帮助。米娜·切西在工作中遇到姐姐发来的紧急短信时，再次想到了这样做的力量。我正坐在教职工会议上，收到了一条短信，我低头一看是我姐姐发来的，于是我打开了它。
less they adjust Red Sox fans or Yankees fans. They become individuals who happen to support those sports teams, individuals with a great many aspects to their identity. Sometimes it's helpful to even just imagine the details of other people's lives in order to stop seeing them purely in terms of their group identity. Mina Sessi was reminded about the power of doing this one time at work when she got an urgent text from her sister. I'm sitting in a faculty meeting and I get a text and I look down and it's from my sister so I opened it.
在短信中，她描述说她刚回到她刚刚搬到的佛罗里达的家中，一进家门发现公寓里有三英尺深的水，她的一切都被毁了。那一刻，我在脑海中极其迅速且生动地想象出她在公寓里的画面。我甚至从未去过那间公寓，但我的大脑自动补全了画面，我看到她站在三英尺深的水中
And in the text she describes that she's just come back to her home in Florida where she had just moved and she's come home to three feet of water in her apartment and that everything she has destroyed. And in that moment, I so quickly and vividly envisioned her in this apartment. I'd never even been to the apartment, but my brain filled it in, and I just saw her standing in three feet of water
不知所措。现在，米娜生动地想象着她的姐姐站在三英尺深的水中，因为她深深地关爱着她的姐姐。但这一刻产生了一个重要的洞见：如果你要求人们生动地想象坏事降临到一个陌生人身上，会发生什么？如果爱能让我们自动设身处地为我们在乎的人着想，那么刻意去尝试设身处地为陌生人着想，
just beside herself. Now, Mina vividly imagined her sister standing in three feet of water because she cared deeply about her sister. But the moment produced an important insight. What would happen if you asked people to vividly imagine something bad happening to a stranger? If love can make us automatically put ourselves in the shoes of the people we care about, could deliberately trying to put ourselves in the shoes of strangers,
能否增强我们与他们的情感联系呢？如果我们指示人们生动地想象这样一个场景：他们必须帮助另一个人。某人在路边从摩托车上摔了下来，而你正准备下车。而那个人要么是内群体成员，要么是一个政治派别的人，或者是外党派的人。我们发现，当我们告诉人们
boost our emotional connection with them? What do we instruct people to vividly imagine a scene in which they have to help another person? Somebody's fallen off their motorcycle by the side of the road, and you're about to get out. And that person is either an in-group member, a political partisan or an out-party person. And what we found was that when we told people
去生动地模拟这个场景时，他们表示自己表达了更多的同理心。但对我们来说更趣的是，当我们告诉人们生动地模拟该场景，而不是仅仅在脑海中重写该场景或考虑另一种措辞方式时，内群体和外群体之间的差距消失了。更有趣的是，我们看到，
to vividly simulate the scenario, they said that they expressed more empathy. But what was even more interesting to us was that the gap between in-group and out-group disappeared when we told them to vividly simulate the scenario as opposed to just rewrite the scenario in their heads or think about a different way of phrasing the scenario. And more interesting than that was that we saw that how,
他们表示自己能够生动地模拟出这个场景的程度，与他们感受到的同理心有多大直接相关。因此，那些告诉我们“我进行了模拟，但在脑海中想象它时遇到了困难”的人，比起那些说“不，我能看到它，我在脑海中看得清清楚楚，这真的触动了他们的心弦”的人，他们对内群体和外群体成员的同理心评分要低得多。所以我们讨论了很多关于我们如何识别自己被群体卷入的时刻
just how vividly they said they were able to simulate it, was related to how much more empathy they had. So people who told us, I simulated, but I had trouble putting it in my mind's eye. Those folks had lower empathy ratings for in-group and out-group members, than those folks who said, no, I could see it. I could see it clear as day in my head, and that really moved the needle for them. So we've talked a lot about how we can recognize moments when we are getting swept up by our
以及我们能为此做些什么。当然，对正在发生的事情和应该做的事情有深刻的见解是一回事，而真正将这些见解付诸实践则是另一回事。我想让你告诉我，你曾有一次在对一个办公室同事的看法上发生了转变的经历。初次见面时，你觉得你和她没有任何共同点。你能告诉我为什么吗，米娜？是的。
groups and what we can do about it. And of course, it's one thing to have insights about what's happening and what to do, and another thing to actually put those insights into practice. I want you to tell me about a time when you once experienced a shift in regard to how you thought about an office mate. On first encounter, you felt like you had nothing in common with her. Can you tell me why, Mina? Yes.
所以，我被安排和特定工作中的一个搭档共用一个办公室。我们见面的那天，她透露了关于她自己的几件事情，让我觉得我和她可能永远不会成为好朋友。例如，她告诉我她认同自己是政治保守派。她还与我分享说她是一个有宗教信仰的人，并且从未离开过我们目前所在的州。而且，你知道的，我们感觉太相反了。在这么多不同的维度上截然相反，我当时想，天哪，这，我不知道这能维持多久，你知道的，我想我们最好还是保持礼貌，把闲聊减少到最低限度。而我对她的看法错得离谱。她是一个了不起的人。她远没有像我的狭隘偏见让我认为的那样思想封闭。我的意思是，她是我们在同事中最有爱心的人之一。
So, I was assigned to an office with a partner in a particular job. The day that we met, she revealed several things about herself that made me feel like she and I would probably never be close friends. So she told me, for example, that she identified as politically conservative. She also shared with me that she was a religious person and she had never lived outside of the state that we were currently in. And just, you know, we just felt so opposite. So diametrically opposed on so many different dimensions, I just thought, gosh, I this, I don't know how long this is going to work, you know, and I guess we should just kind of keep it civil and keep chit-chat to a minimum. And I couldn't have been more wrong about her. She was an amazing person. She wasn't nearly as close-minded as, you know as my close-minded prejudice has made me think she might be. I mean, she was among the most caring people
当大家生病时，她总是特意去为他们买药。她在别人生日时烤蛋糕给大家吃。但更重要的是，除了是一个非常好的人和一个非常好的朋友之外，她思想也很开放。她支持那些生活方式与她的信仰并不十分契合的朋友。她从不因为人们做出的选择而评判他们。如果他们需要她，她总会在那里。这向我展示了，在这段关系中，实际上思想封闭的人更多是我，而不是她。真正带来改变的是，当你更深入地了解她之后，
of the people we worked with. She was always going out of her way to pick up medicine for people when they got sick. She baked people things on their birthdays. But more importantly, above and beyond just being a very good person and a very good friend, she was also open. She was supportive of our friends who live lifestyles
她作为一个人所拥有的细节，本质上取代了你对她广泛层面的刻板印象。没错。我脑子里有这样一个模板，而她根本不像那个模板。我花在她身上的时间越多，我就越意识到那个模板有多么离谱。你和她保持联系了吗？她还是你保持联系的人吗？她明天就要走了。听到她的消息你会高兴吗？哦，只要她开口，哪怕让我放下手头所有的事情我都愿意。
that didn't really comport with her beliefs. She'd never judged people for the choices that they made. If they needed her, she was there. It just revealed to me how much it was actually me who was the close-minded person in the situation much more than her. And what made the difference really was, as you got to know her better, the details of
值得注意的是，我们讨论了群体引导我们误入歧途的种种方式，但从某些方面来看，群体塑造我们的方式中也存在着一种深刻的悖论。你曾谈到过这个悖论，即群体有时会以非常糟糕的方式伤害我们，但它们也能以非常好的方式帮助我们。米娜，你能谈谈这个吗？我觉得我们花了很多时间讨论群体如何将我们引向歧途，但这并不是它们在我们生活中扮演的唯一角色。
who she was as a person essentially subsumed your stereotypes of who she was at a very broad level. That's right. I had this model in my head and she just wasn't anything like that model. And the more time that I spent with her, the more I realized just how wrong that model was. And have you I spent with her, the more I realized just how wrong that model was. And have you stayed friends with her? Is she still someone you were in touch with? Is she gone in touch tomorrow? Would you be glad to hear from her? Oh, I would drop everything to do anything she asked me to.
没错。我非常感谢有机会表达这一点，因为我确实花了大量时间思考冲突，以及群体间动态给人类带来的所有痛苦和苦难。但很显然，群体也是我们取得最大成就的源泉。作为集体，我们共同完成的事情远远超出了我们单枪匹马所能做到的。群体
It's worth noting that we've talked about the many ways in which groups can lead us astray, but there's also in some ways a deep paradox in the way that groups shape us. And you've talked about this paradox, which is that groups can serve us in really bad ways, but they can also serve us in really good ways. Can you talk about that for a moment, Meena? I feel like we've spent a lot of time discussing the ways in which groups can lead us astray, but that's not the only role they play in our lives.
在照顾彼此、产生归属感、赋予人们意义感、目标感和共同现实感方面发挥着非常重要的作用。你知道的，它们让我们在充满复杂情况和巨大不确定性的复杂世界中免于感到迷失方向。因此，我认为强调群体为我们所做的一切好事，它们帮助组织我们的感受的方式，同样是极其重要的。
That's right. And I really appreciate the opportunity to articulate this because I do spend so much of my time thinking about conflict and all of the pain and suffering that intergroup dynamics have wrought on humanity. But it's so clear, of course, that groups are also the source of our greatest triumphs. The things that we can accomplish together as collectives are so much more than anything we could do by ourselves. And groups
还有我们的思想、价值观和优先事项，它们让我们清楚地知道我们在乎什么，以及我们想把时间和精力投入到哪里。所以如果你问我，如果可以的话，你会不会挥一挥手让群体这个概念从人类历史上永远抹去？答案当然是不会，对吧？因为它们本身蕴含着巨大的向善潜力。对我而言，目标是尽可能地减少群体走向对立的情况，以及减少由此类情况产生的一切后果。
serve really important functions for taking care of one another, feeling a sense of belonging, giving people a sense of meaning, purpose, and shared reality. You know, they keep us from feeling unmoored in a really complicated world with a lot of really complicated circumstances and so much uncertainty. And so, I do think it's incredibly important also to highlight all the good that groups do for us, the way that they help organize our feelings
米娜·奇卡拉是哈佛大学的心理学家。米娜，非常感谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、罗恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
and our thoughts and our values and our priorities, how they make clear for us what it is that we care about and where we want to devote our time and our energy. So if you were to ask me, would you with a wave of your hand abolish the notion of groups from humanity forever and ever if you could? And the answer is of course not, right? Because they carry with them so much potential for good. For me, the goal is to try to mitigate where we can when it is that groups turn against
我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。今天节目的最后，我们为您带来一则来自我们的姊妹播客《我无名英雄》（My Unsung Hero）的故事。故事的主人公是一位名叫珍妮弗的女士。为了保护她的隐私，我们只使用她的名字。小时候，珍妮弗觉得自己总是无法融入集体。同学们嘲笑她社交笨拙、穿着老土。去学校就像是一种折磨。但到了七年级，霸凌升级到了一个全新的水平。有一帮女孩——如今我们可能会管她们叫“Mean Girls（贱女孩）”——她们把整年折磨我当作自己的一大特殊爱好。她们会在走廊里等我
each other and all of the fallout from those kinds of circumstances. MINA CHICARA is a psychologist at Harvard University. MINA, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
在下课的时候，以便她们可以立刻开始找我麻烦。她们会把我和学校里一个叫“draw off”的区域围起来，在那里她们会围成一个圈来侮辱我。对此我没有任何防御能力。无论她们对我说什么侮辱的话，我都原封不动地还给她们。所以她们会说：“你真笨。”而我会说：“不，你才笨。”“你真丑。”而我会说：“不，你才丑。”那一年的学校生活糟透了。我痛苦不堪。我的成绩一塌糊涂。大多数日子里，我在放学回家的路上都在哭泣，试图整理好情绪。这样我母亲就不会知道发生了什么。在七年级和八年级之间的那个夏天，这个女孩帮派的领头人不幸在一场车祸中丧生。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Today we end the show with a story from our sister podcast My Unsung Hero. It comes from a woman named Jennifer. We're only using her first name to protect her privacy. As a kid, Jennifer felt like she never quite fit in. Her classmates made fun of her for being socially awkward and wearing unfashionable clothes. Going to school felt like torture. But the bullying escalated to a whole new level in seventh grade. There was a gang of girls that these days we'd call them the mean girls who made it their special hobby to torment me all year. And they would wait for me in the hallway
尽管我从未希望她们中的任何人遭遇那种事，我真的只是希望她们不要再找我的麻烦了，但我确实抱有一丝希望，这可能意味着八年级会变得不同。而这种希望在新学年开始仅仅两天后就破灭了。我发现那帮女孩依然聚在一起，她们有了一个新的领头人。是一个来自外地或另一个学区的女孩，我一无所知。每当她们有空的时候，她们就会像往常一样找到我，像往常一样折磨我。我又开始痛苦了。
at the end of class so that they could start picking on me right away. And they would corner me in this area of the school called the draw off where they would kind of form a ring around me and insult me. And I had no defense against any of this. I would just, whatever insult they said to me, I just said right back to them. So they would say, you're stupid. And I'd say, no, you're stupid. You're ugly. And I'd say, no, you're ugly. The school year was terrible. I was miserable. My grades were terrible. I cried most days on the way home from school trying to get myself together. So my mother wouldn't know what was going on. In the summer between 7th and 8th grade, the ringleader of this gang of girls was tragically killed in a car accident.
直到开学大约六周后，我在上完体育课后换衣服，我等到其他孩子都走了，好能独自换衣服，这时我听到一个声音。我抬起头，看到那个新的头目站在那里，看起来很生气。她说：“我想跟你聊聊。”我吓坏了。她说：“我的手下告诉我，你一直在侮辱她们。”我简直不敢相信这不公正的指责。我开始哭泣。她说：“你哭什么？”我只记得当时心里想：我死定了。我死定了。
And although I had never wished anything like that on any of them, I really just had wanted them to stop picking on me, I did hold out some hope that this might mean that 8th grade could be different. And that hope lasted about two days into the new school year. When I discovered that the gang of girls was still together, they had a new ring later. Some girl who had come from out of town or another school district, I have no idea. And whenever they could get free, they would come find me as always and torment me as always. And I was miserable again.
我在这个女孩面前哭了。而这让情况变得更糟。当情况变得如此糟糕时，整个故事就像倒豆子一样从我嘴里倾泻而出。我告诉她这些女孩在整个七年级是怎么折磨我的，以及我对她们说的任何侮辱的话，
Until about six weeks into the school year, when I was changing after gym class, I'd waited till all the other kids were gone so that I could change in private when I hear a voice. And I look up and there was the new ringleader standing there looking angry. She said, I want to talk to you. And I was terrified. She said, my girls tell me that you've been insulting them. And I was just so surprised at the injustice of it. And I just began to cry. She said, what are you crying about? And I just, I just remembered thinking I was dead. I'm dead.
没有一句是她们在十秒钟前没有对我说过的。整个故事从我口中倾泻而出，我记得自己坐在体育馆的长椅上，盯着长椅，看着我的大颗眼泪啪嗒啪嗒地滴落在长椅的木板上。随后是一阵漫长的沉默，接着我听到她说：“对不起。我不知道这些，我会告诉她们停手的。”当我抬起头时，她已经不见了。那些女孩再也没有跟我说过话。她把她自己和她的朋友们彻底从我的生活中隔绝了。在那之后，我能够去学校上学、集中精力、茁壮成长、交朋友并建立美好的未来。
I'm crying in front of this girl. And that just made it worse. And when it got that bad, the whole story just tumbled out of me and I talked to her about how these girls had tormented me all the way through seventh grade and how no insult I had ever thrown at them. Was anything they hadn't said to me ten seconds before
我对世界的看法与如果没有发生这件事会有所不同。比起以前，我更愿意给别人以信任。在令人生畏的情况下，我比以前更敞开心扉。这一切都是因为我的无名英雄让我看到了前所未有的人性。我不知道要在中学里当所有人都作恶时坚持做正确的事需要什么样的品格力量，但她做到了。如果我今天能告诉她这件事，我会告诉她，她不仅改变了我的生活——虽然她确实做到了——
The whole story pours out of me and I can remember sitting on the gym bench I'm staring down at the bench watching my big tears splatting on the on the blacker of the bench and The long silence followed and then I hear her say I'm sorry. I didn't know that, I'll tell them to stop. And when I looked up, she was gone. And those girls never spoke to me again. She removed herself and her friends from my life completely. And after that, I was able to go to school and to concentrate and to flourish and to make friends and to build a good future.
她改变了整个世界。谢谢你。珍妮弗目前在马里兰州生活和工作。如果我们的节目触动了您，请考虑进行经济捐赠以支持我们。您可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。网址再重复一遍，是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本·尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。西亚辛。此剧集暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
I approached the world very differently than I would have had this not happened. I give people the benefit of the doubt more than I would have. I open myself up in intimidating situations more than I would have. All things that I did because my unsung hero gave me a view of humanity I had never had before. I don't know what kind of strength of character it must take to do the right thing in middle school when nobody does the right thing, but she did. And if I could tell her about that today, I would tell her that she didn't just change my life, though she did.
我对世界的看法与如果没有发生这件事时会有很大不同。我比过去更能给予别人信任。在令人胆怯的情境下，我比过去更愿意敞开心扉。所有这些改变，都是因为我的无名英雄让我看到了前所未见的对人性的理解。我不知道要在初中时所有人都没做正确的事时坚持做正确的事，需要多么强大的品格力量，但她做到了。如果我今天能把这件事告诉她，我会告诉她，她不仅改变了我的生活，尽管她的确做到了。
She changed the whole world. So thank you. Jennifer now lives and works in Maryland. If our show speaks to you, please consider making a financial gift to support us. You can do so at support.hiddenbrain.org. That side again is support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Ben Şankar Vedantım. Siyasın. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她改变了整个世界。谢谢你。詹妮弗现在住在马里兰州并工作。如果我们的节目能触动你，请考虑给予经济支持。你可以访问 support.hiddenbrain.org 进行捐赠。网址再次是 support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。政治。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。